[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers and her
friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my
seventh episode of Queen trap sack lines
in this episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful Queen sacrifice line in the
French - main line from the black
respecting the opening arises after the
following model E 4 e 6 d 4 D 5 and now
the typical tirage volition start with
night 2 D 2 defending a fold
black plays Knight to f6 attacking on e4
and initially white place the move 'if i
not only grabbing the space in the
center but attacking on f6 Knight we are
going to follow the main line for a
while Knight F to d7 Bishop to d3 so
that Bishop has been placed on a
wonderful diagonal and accordingly black
play systemic French defense break c5
which tried to undermine the white pawn
chain and especially the base on d4
white is going to defend this with c3
and now the pressurization of B 4
squared start with Knight to c6 Knight
to e2 this Knight move is more accurate
than the f3 square as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows those knight
has a great future and at least they are
not interfering each other we have few
captures on the center see captors
deform see captors deform and if you
recall at this point
in my chest trap 20 video I have
suggested the MU websites where if white
continue with the mu F fall then he fall
into one of the amazing trap of the
French tirage and almost all the
additions plaque get a very superior
position so if you haven't check it out
I strongly insist you to go and watch
that video however in this video I am
going to propose the other popular
choice by black namely Queen to b6
pressurising d4 and the obvious move
from the white knight to f3 once again
defending the d4
okay the second time attic break occurs
now with AB 6 and with this move white
can no longer keep his spawn chain so
the best white can do over here is to
capture on f6 and after Knight captures
AB six black achieve his first goal to
destroy the white pawn chain in the
center of the board okay the mainline
continuous weed castle on the King side
black plays Bishop to d6 so now black
Bishop has been placed on a wonderful
diagonal and same time black is ready to
castle and white replies faith Knight to
c3
so obviously that Knight is not doing
anything on e2 at least on c3 it has
some purpose and on top of everything
White has set up a cunning trap if black
is foolish enough and thinks that the d4
pawn hangs then it's a great mistake as
after Knight captures d4
white can simply capture this Knight and
now black can no longer regain his piece
because if he played Queen captures d4
then Bishop to b5 and black Queen is a
corner so it is very clear that black
cannot touch that pawn and as for the
database the most frequent choice by
black is to castle on the Kings side
however I am going to propose a
different move and that is Bishop to d7
with this move first thing black has
done is he has covered the EH to a4
diagonal and accordingly White has
to popular choice in this position if
your opponent continued here with Bishop
to e3 and then my recommendation is you
should castle on the King side and
follow the main line which in fact give
black a decent equality however in this
video we are going to concentrate on the
move
a3 which looks more natural in this
position as it not only stop any black
intrusion on b4 square but the same time
hoping that black and capture on d4
square
well so far White's play is very natural
and good except the last move a3 is a
big time error and in fact in the online
database there are more than 80 games
played from this position so if you are
a French player then you are likely to
get this position in the tournament
practice before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out what is
wrong with the move a3 and how black can
exploit it well you are a genius if you
play this move boom ha ha ha well at
first sight this looks impossible right
because y can simply take this and now
you cannot take this 9 let's say black
take this then ok black has stopped the
move Bishop to b5 check but this time he
has the other check and that is Bishop
to g6 and I bet white players eyes will
literally lit up when they see this move
has after Bishop to g6 check black Queen
is simply out of the game
and yes indeed true black doesn't have
any good choice here black have to take
this bishop and no wonder after Queen
captures d4 white is dreaming of
finishing off black very quickly but
after blacks next reply Bishop captures
s2 in fact the reverse is true it's a
check so white King has the only square
King to edge fun and after Bishop to e5
discover check to the King King to
Jeevan Bishop captures d4 the result of
the whole forcing sequence turns out
that not only black regain his lost
Queen but at the end he get to pawn an
extra Bishop which is a huge huge
winning advantage for the black so this
is one of the wonderful counter Queen
trap exists in the French defense which
can caught a lot of off-guard opponent
before I leave there is one point I like
to mention that in some books
Knight to be Phi has been recommended
but I don't think so this provide any
solution to the white cam as after the
accurate response Queen to e5 so we are
threatening Quint west to checkmate and
it doesn't matter whether white continue
with g3 or f4 it is only black who is
coming on top of all the variations for
example if your opponent continues with
the move f4 then the simplest is you
first deliver this chat and after king -
h1 and Quinn to b8 sooner or later we
will kick this night with a 6 and there
is hardly any compensation for the lost
pawn well same goes for the MU g3 as
after Bishop to b8 Bishop to f4 the key
thing you have to remember is do not
capture on b2 but simply play Queen to
h5 and thus Queen exchange cannot be
denied
white bone structure will be ruined so
the sample line can draw like this
Knight to c7 creating a folk Bishop
capture c7 Queen captures h5 Knight
captures h5 Bishop capture c7 Knight to
f6 Bishop b5 and now King to f7 it's
okay that White has a bishop pair but
the important factor is black has a
runner on the D file which is not easy
to stop and with some careful play I'm
definitely sure that black can obtain a
full point well that's it guys I hope
you enjoy and learn this wonderful Queen
counter sec line in the french tourist
vision so far I have kept some higher
and player in this line so remember when
your opponent plays a3 give him this
hope of capturing your Queen with Knight
captures d4 and after Knight captures d4
Queen captures d4 and Bishop to g6 yes
you are losing your queen but at the end
it is only black who is having the last
laugh as black Riggin the queen with
some heavy interest thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care